pour ceux qui se posent la question ceci
n'est pas un accessoire de mode mais une
attelle ce que je me suffis connement
une tendinite
alors là tout connement mais bon ça on
s'en fout la limite aujourd'hui on est
là pour parler de quatre cas de 4k et de
scie il faut vraiment utilisé et si
c'est vraiment utile d'utiliser de la 4k
et de filmer en 4k
[Musique]
et salut les amis aujourd'hui c'est la
gueule et salut les amis aujourd'hui on
va parler d'eux 4k parce que je vois
partout en fait des gens qui disent il
faut absolument finir en 4k la 4k c'est
trop cool
l'acca de casser ce qui vous donnera la
meilleure image possible
et bah je ne suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec ça alors juste un petit
point de théorique l'a4 cas c'est ce
qu'on appelle de l'ultra hd c'est grosso
modo une résolution quatre fois
supérieur à l'âge dit alors comme ça
c'est sûr qu'on pourrait se dire bah si
c'est 4 fois supérieure forcément c'est
vachement plus intéressant de faire avec
et on va en parler un petit peu et puis
on va surtout voir les avantages et les
inconvénients de la 4k pour vous aider à
faire votre choix sur quel format sur
quelle résolution vous allez pouvoir
filmer l'avant ça serait un petit peu de
repérage photo donc je vais vous montrer
un petit peu là où je suis et puis
justement il ya des plans qui vont être
en 4k et d'autres qui vont pas être en
cas de cas donc je vous laisse chercher
je vous laisse me dire dans les
commentaires si vous avez repéré quand
c'était aller ce parti
[Musique]
alors les avantages de la 4k déjà la
première chose par définition justement
c'est le bon mot c'est la définition
effectivement on va avoir une définition
qui va être bien plus importante que ce
soit de la hd on va avoir même si on
donne scale c'est à dire que après on
utilise ça et on exporte en 1080 en full
hd
on va très souvent avoir une résolution
bien meilleure qu'avec du full hd en
enregistrant en full hd
alors je prends des pincettes quand même
ça dépend des caméras et ça va dépendre
des codecs qui sont utilisés mais
généralement sur un même appareil en cas
de cas on aura quand même une meilleure
qualité d'image qu'en full hd sur le
même appareil parce que bien sûr si vous
prenez de la 4k d'un smartphone et de la
full hd d'une caméra full frame
forcément la meilleure définition la
meilleure qualité sera très souvent sur
le full frame
l'autre gros avantage de la 4k ça va
être que si on monte notre projet en
1080 malgré qu'on est filmé en 4k on va
pouvoir croupit dans l'image va pouvoir
recadrer très facilement sans perdre en
définition c'est à dire que comme on a
une définition quatre fois supérieur à
la hd
grosso modo pour faire simple on va
pouvoir zoomer quatre fois dans l'image
sans perdre en définition alors que si
je filme en full hd et que je monte en
full hd
je fais ce fameux zoom ben là je vais
vraiment avoir des pixels on va voir les
détails des petits défauts et on va
avoir une image qui va être dégradée et
enfin le dernier avantage que je vois la
carcasse et la durabilité c'est à dire
que là aujourd'hui
le standard on va dire que c'est quand
même le 1080 c'est la hd la plupart des
gens regardent leurs vidéos en 1080 que
ce soit sur le smartphone etc
il ya la 4k c'est quand même réservé à
des gens qui ont un bon débit internet
déjà parce que pour pouvoir regarder du
streaming en cas de casse et il faut
quand même un peu de débit mais rien ne
dit que d'ici deux trois quatre ans
la 4k ça va être le standard et que tout
le monde regardera ses vidéos en 4k et
auquel cas la vidéo que vous aurez filmé
en cas de cas il ya quelques années elle
sera toujours d'actualité
moi j'avoue je regarde des vidéos que
j'ai filmer en 720p il ya quelques
années et j'ai un petit peu les boules
de hasard filmer en 720p en me disant ça
va être plus léger pour le montage ça va
être plus facile et c est franchement si
j'avais su j'aurais filmer en hd
donc voilà il ya de gros avantage à
filmer en 4k mais il ya aussi de gros
inconvénients
et ça je vous en parlais tout de suite
le temps d'aller tourner le matin tôt
dans l'herbe
j'ai les pieds trempés et ça fait trente
minutes que on tourne voilà les boules
c'est ça c'est la vie c'est la vie de
vie des lycées mais de pire en pire
le truc c'est voilà un python ah oui et
tant que j'y pense peut cliquer sur la
vidéo qui s'affiche ici sur votre écran
parce que avec ce principe de crop vous
allez pouvoir également créé des faux
mouvements de caméra donc je vous en dis
pas plus mais cliquer sur la vidéo cayla
et franchement vous allez voir ça peut
être vachement sympa aussi de filmer en
4k justement pour ces faux effets de
caméra
alors qu'on a parlé des avantages
maintenant on va parler des
inconvénients de la 4k le plus gros
inconvénient de la 4k à mon sens c'est
simplement le poids des fichiers la 4k
ça donne des fichiers énorme et qui dit
gros fichiers dits aussi gros stockage
san van
derrière un rapport à la taille donc si
vous filmez en 4k ça dépend de la durée
en fait des films que vous faites mais
il va falloir prévoir des cartes sd
conséquente voir un l'autre carte sd qui
va bien les disques durs qui vont avec
si vous archiver vos proches
donc voilà déjà c'est ça implique un
minimum de matériel
sans compter que la 4k même si on peut
utiliser des proxy et ça je vous en
parle dans la vidéo qui est juste ici la
4k ça reste quelque chose de lourd à
traiter même si on fait des proxys va à
l'export il va falloir quand même
traiter les fichiers 4k donc ça veut
dire qu'il va falloir aussi en plus des
stockages et des disques durs conséquent
il va falloir un ordi qui bastonne quand
même un minimum pour pouvoir traiter ça
correctement ou ou de tout simplement ne
pas y passer des heures rien qu'à
l'export donc c'est impliquant voir faut
bien spécifiques pour traiter tout ça et
ça peut quand même être relativement
handicapante si on a besoin de faire les
choses vite pour être lus au delà de ça
si vous faites des vidéos sur youtube
la majorité des gens regardent les
vidéos sur un smartphone la question que
je me pose c'est est ce que vraiment on
va voir la différence entre de la 4k sur
un smartphone ou du 1080
je suis pas certain ça va pas être
flagrant de chez flagrant est ce que ça
vaut vraiment le coup de faire vos
vidéos en 4k sachant que la différence
va être minime donc la 4k c'est bien
c'est cool mais il faut avoir en tête
tous ces inconvénients
alors vous allez me dire oui mais bon du
coup moi je fais quoi 1084 cas on va
voir ça tout de suite ce jeu juste vous
montrer un petit peu l'a fait dans un
autre endroit
et puis juste après je vous dis moi
comment je fonctionne par rapport à la
4k
[Musique]
à
il n'est même pas 10 heures il fait au
moins huit mille degrés je vais décédé
alors quatre caps à quatre cabanes en
fête c'est un peu comme dans tout c'est
à dire c'est une histoire de compromis
avec je viens de m'asseoir sur mcleish
gamme de mini trous et une fesse alors
moi personnellement j'ai fait le choix
d'alterner entre les deux il ya des
choses que je filme en 4k des choses que
je filme en 1080p un exemple tout bête
si je couvre un mariage si j'ai des
heures de rush dans la journée je vais
pas filmer en 4k tout simplement parce
que déjà ça va être très lourd en
stockage et ensuite je vais galérer pour
le film même si j'ai un ordi qui
bombarde un taux bas ça va être
compliqué ça va être les temps de rendre
vont être longs et au final fin je vais
m'agacer sur le montage et ça va me
gonfler par contre sur des projets cours
des choses qui vont durer deux trois
minutes et un clip ou des choses comme
ça je vais peut-être m'orienter vers la
4k
sauf si bas j'ai du slow motion à faire
puisque très souvent sur les appareils
plus vous allez augmenter la définition
moins vous aurez d'image par seconde
possible par exemple la sur le sur le à
cette je crois que ça plafonne à 60
images par seconde et - montceau mots
j'aime bien le faire à 100 ou 120 images
par seconde donc l'idée pour choisir si
on va filmer ou pas en 4k ça va être
quel est le projet à quoi va servir la
vidéo parce que voilà pour résumer la 4k
ça vous permettre d'avoir une super
image
la plupart du temps je prend des
pincettes avec ça parce que la 4k ce
n'est pas forcément un gage d'image
fantastique mais la contrepartie c'est
que c'est super lourd et ça va être
chiant remonter ça va être chaud stocker
un champ tout est relatif à toujours
avec les histoires de proxy ça peut
passer aussi mais voilà c'est pas non
plus voilà donc ce que je vous
recommande moi c'est bac quand vous
pouvez finir en 4k quand vous savez
quand vous avez anticipé que ça va pas
être trop lourd à gérer derrière
n'hésitez pas à foncer mais pour des
projets longs ou des projets riches en
rush vous aller filmer beaucoup là ça
vaut le coup de se poser la question est
ce que ça vaut pas le coup que je finis
finalement en 1080 plutôt qu'en cas de
cas est ce que je vais pas finalement
gagner du temps pour un résultat qui va
être à peu près la même chose puisque je
vais exporté en 1080p toute façon on
l'export en 4k ça sert à rien car sur
youtube en tout cas l'export en 4k il
vraiment très très peu de d'intérêt
puisque ne serait ce qu'en termes de
débit la 4k ça demande quand même
voilà c'est sur son smartphone avec une
connexion qui envoie du lourd et puis de
toute façon sur un écran petit comme ça
vous ne va pas voir la différence entre
l'export en 4k et l'export en 1080 dans
tous les cas l'export en 1080 je pense
que c'est nécessaire je vois pas
l'intérêt vraiment de d'exporter en
quatre si ce n'est pour une minorité de
gens qui y ont accès et la majorité des
gens va regarder ça en 1080 même des
fois un peu son débit dans des
résolutions encore moindre mais finit en
4k ça peut être intéressant pour le
groupe mais pas tout le temps pas tout
le temps voilà ma conclusion donc voilà
pour cette vidéo estivale j'espère
qu'elle vous a plu si c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à mettre le traditionnel
coûte blaster sur le pouce qui se situe
en dessous de cette vidéo à le pouce en
l'air de préférence ou le pouce en bas
c'est jeanne et puis si vous aimez la
vidéo n'hésitez pas à vous abonner en
soi films séries ou vidéos youtube
ici on parle de tout ça bon et puis
comme d'habitude moi je vous dis rester
curieux et à très bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo
je crois qu'aujourd'hui en fait tous les
mecs ont décidé de passer
débroussailleuse ou de signer des trucs
en fait ils aux endroits où je suis allé
filmer ces trois endroits différents et
trois endroits il ya un mec qui passe la
débroussailleuse donc balle aille se
sont donné le mot merci les gars récolté
plaisir